from now on
I am no longer the candidate of a camp
but the president of all and all
this new era will not be the
continuity of the quinquennium which is ending
but the collective invention of a
method felt for five years of
better  service of our country
[Music]
in this defeat I cannot help but
feel a form of hope
this result constitutes for our
French leaders as for the
European leaders the testimony of a
great mistrust of the French people
towards them that they  cannot ignore and
that of the widely shared aspiration
of a great change
the frenchman i'm not very proud of the
fact that we have funky style just like
center of your or your very strong far
right candidates there also this false tra
so that a place in bahrain of the
representatives of the second round of the
presidential election and things we are
all right thing you do this kind of
situate
[Applause]
[Music]
I know that  e for many of our
compatriots
who today chose the far
right anger is the disagreements
that led them to vote for this project
must also find an answer it
will be my responsibility and that of those
around me